>>> TONIGHT, DODGING QUESTIONS.
MAJORITY LEADER, MITCH McCONNELL
, RESPONDING TO NEWS THAT RON
JOHNSON TRIED TO HAND OFF A
SLATE OF ELECTORS TO MIKE
PENCE.
>> YOU SHOULD ASK SENATOR
JOHNSON ABOUT THAT.
>> JOHNSON HAS BEEN ASKED. HE'S
SAYING NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
WE ARE OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: THERE IS NO
CONSPIRACY HERE.
A COMPLETE NONSTORY.
WHEN IT COMES TO SENATORS
JOHNSONS INVOLVEMENT, HE TRIED
TO PUT FORWARD UP VASE OF
ELECTORS.
>> SOME INTERNS SAID THE VICE
PRESIDENT NEEDS THIS.
I WASN'T INVOLVED.
>> Reporter: THE WISCONSIN
REPUBLICAN SAID THERE'S NOTHING
TO SEE HERE.
>> WE GOT HANDED AN ENVELOPE.
THOUGH VICE PRESIDENT WANTED IT
AND WE DELIVERED IT.
>> Reporter: HE DIDN'T CREATE
FAKE ELECTORS FROM MICHIGAN AND
WISCONSIN AND HE DIDN'T DELIVER
THEM.
THAT HE DID EMBRACE THE
ELECTIONS CELEBRATION.
>> WE ARE SAYING LET'S DELAY
ACCEPTING THE ELECTORS UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATE WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE IN THAT STATE.
>> Reporter: UNDERLINING THIS
CONTROVERSY THAT HE'S WAITED
INTO.
NOW HE HAS FIRE POWER BY
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS.
AFTER THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION, JOHNSON WOULD'VE
BEEN MORE'S VOCAL IF HE FACED
BLACK LIVES MATTER PROTEST.
>> PEOPLE THAT TRULY RESPECT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD NEVER DO
ANYTHING TO BREAK THE LAW.
THE TABLES HAVE BEEN TURNED AND
HAD PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION AND THOSE WERE BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND NT THE
PROTESTERS, I MIGHT'VE BEEN
CONCERNED.
>> MANY SAID THAT WAS RACIST.
THE SENATOR SAID THAT WASN'T
HIS INTENT. THEY MERELY ARE
ASKING QUESTIONS.
HE'S MADE HEADLINES FOR HIS
OUTLANDISH CLAIMS LIKE
DISMISSING CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> THE SCIENCE OF MAN CAUSED
CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT PROVEN BY
ANY STRETCH OF THE IMAGINATION.
>> Reporter: AND ABOUT THE
CORONA VIRUS VACCINE.
EVEN SUGGESTING ATHLETES WERE
DROPPING DEAD AFTER GETTING THE
SHOT.
>> WE'VE HEARD STORY AFTER
STORY OF ATHLETES DROPPING DEAD
ON THE FIELD.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO IGNORE THAT
NOTHING HAPPENED HERE. NOTHING
TO SEE.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY AND A
SCANDAL.
>> EVEN TODAY WHEN RON JOHNSON
WAS ASKING THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE ELECTORS, THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
JOHNSON HAS BACKED AWAY FROM
ANY OF THESE ABSURD CLAIMS.
>> Reporter: HE'S NOT BACKING
DOWN FROM ANY OF THE
CONTROVERSIES.
VACCINE ISSUE HE SAID HE WANTS
TO BRING UP THE POTENTIAL
ADVERSE EFFECTS EVEN THOUGH
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF THEM.
EVEN THOUGH, OF COURSE, THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE THE ATHLETES
DROP DEAD ON THE FIELD.
THE SPOKESPERSON SAID THAT IN
THE PAST TWO ELECTIONS,
AMERICANS HAVE QUESTIONED THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE RESULTS.
HE B